all right so will president Trump should
president Trump sit down for an
interview with the Special Counsel
Robert Muller joining us now with
reaction president Trump's attorney Jay
Sekulow Jay great to see you is a very
same question of Gregg Jarrett and judge
Perot and every other attorney Joe
digenova
I've talked to almost every attorneys
Universal and saying absolutely not can
you give this an update
sure well the first thing is look you've
got to start with this proposition the
depth of corruption that led to this
investigation and that frankly continues
to permeate this investigation is
unprecedented so you have to start with
that you mentioned in the earlier
segment the irregularities and that's
being kind of what took place here so
you have to start with the question of
whether the president would sit for an
interview with the proposition is there
a constitutional basis upon which that
interview can take place now it frankly
it is the position of the legal team and
it's been pretty clear on this in the
last couple of weeks that our position
is that there is not a constitutional
basis to move an interview forward and
what I mean by that is the article 2
power of the presidency is very clear
and the idea that you would have a
series of questions involving the
president's motives for particular
actions as it relates to article 2 power
would frankly be inappropriate in our
view unconstitutional so then you ask
yourself does that answer the question
well look the president stated that he
wants to do an interview I will tell you
the position of the legal team is that
we do not advise that
however there continues to be ongoing
discussions and dialogue with the Office
of Special Counsel to see if there is
something that can be worked out that we
would be comfortable with short of that
the answer of course is no but if they
ultimately the one that makes that
determination though the lawyers can
advise is the President of the United
States so he will make that decision
obviously in consultation with his legal
team and by the way and you've been my
counsel my question if you told me
absolutely not
I don't think you would appreciate or
accept me saying I'm gonna do it anyway
that's my I you know
you want to you know so I understand
that Shawn but you're not the President
of the United States so it's there's a
different calculus yeah clearly our
inclination look clearly the inclination
is no and you could I could put a
hundred lawyers in the room and a
hundred of them are going to say that I
make the joke when I'm talking to two
reporters that you know if we put the
print isn't it up for an interview
you're gonna have 12 lawyers saying I
can't believe they did it if you don't
put the president up for an interview
those same two where those same 12
lawyers gonna say what are they hiding
but if you look at the constitutional
issues that are implicated by an by an
interview it's very serious
it raises very serious constitutional
issues that go to the heart of you as
you mentioned earlier separation of
powers article 2 Authority I've been
saying that for a year and nothing's
changed in that regard ultimately the
decisions up to the president we will
give advice but there are ongoing
discussions to see if there could be
stay if something worked out here I look
at the team that Muller's put together
the president has tweeted about the team
he's put together I look at Andrew
Weissman's atrocious record including
let's see putting innocent people in
jail overturned I know in the Supreme
Court overturned 5-4 and overturned in
the Fifth Circuit tens of thousands of
people lose their job
withholding exculpatory evidence now I'm
not trying to drag you into that that
that battle but I got to ask you is it a
pro it's about the two questions would
be about obstruction and collusion
there's no evidence of collusion can we
compare what they're accusing the
president of with Adam shifts tape where
he's like you know excited because he's
talking to a Russian that has dirt on
Donald Trump supposedly turns out to be
a hoax is a collusion Hillary paid for
Russian lies before the election and it
was used to get there's two things here
first of all I think we got to be clear
on this this idea that there's been no
evidence put forward on any type of
collusion between the President and and
and Russian said I mean no one's put
evidence forward on that now that's
number one number two let me tell you
this when people say the word
obstruction I went to everybody
understand the context which this is
arising this is arising in decisions
that a president makes under his
authority under Article two who's gonna
work for him who's not going to work for
him where things are developed where
they're not what policy positions they
with policy positions they do not the
idea that that would constitute some
kind of violation of the law to me seems
you know not only a bizarre legal theory
and untested but frankly out of order
under our Constitution but let's go back
you're using these examples of the
people involved in the investigation on
the legal team let's go to what started
this investigation in the first place
you had an unverified dossier put
together by Christopher Steele who ends
up getting fired by the FBI for linking
James Comey wants a special counsel so
he leaks a memo that he created based on
a conversation that he had with the
president now if an FBI agent did that
could you imagine the repercussions of
leaking that memo then it gets even
better you've got the number four at the
United States Department of Justice I
know you've already talked about this
Bruce or whose wife is working for
fusion GPS Nellie or and what is her job
her job is to work with Christopher
Seale the former British intelligence
officer who's putting together the
dossier against the president now you
know what the fact is no one could it's
hard to believe that those are really
the facts you know what the problem is
Shawn those are the facts and really no
one has disputed any of those facts so
the problem here is a foundational
problem that's why I say the
irregularities and and the corruption
involved in the process from the
beginning is really unprecedented so all
of that factors into the decision that's
ultimately made whether they'll be an
advanced key or not whether it'll be
written questions or not that decision
we're close to making that decision I
don't ever give dates I think it ends
soon but I cannot give you the date
because here's what happens let me give
you the process bob muller under his
authority will issue a report that
report though does not go to the
congress this is not a independent
council it would go to the Deputy
Attorney General who's the acting
Attorney General and then he will
determine what goes forward at the same
time quite frankly we are developing a
report that is going to lay out all of
these issues that we've talked about so
that's how this is not a trial and
people need a I think people understand
that now this is not a trial in the
traditional sense of anything
this is a political process that is
going forward and I want to be clear
here the constitutional issues which is
the reason I got it was involved in this
case in the first place in fact are the
major issues that this issue that this
investigation turns on there are serious
constitutional implications of this not
just for this president but for the
presidency and that's what history will
remember so that's why we've got to be
very careful and very direct on how we
move forward let me ask you one last
question if I may yep the president has
the power to declassify all of the
subpoenaed documents that Congress has
been withholding and they've been not
they've not been living up to the
subpoena sigh I don't think I'd get away
with that even with you as my great
attorney
yeah the president has the power to
demand they be literally unredacted and
released why doesn't he do that well
look he's respecting a process that's in
place that his White House team that is
not a decision we make as his private
lawyers as his as counsel of the
president we are not the White House
Counsel so that's a decision that's made
within the context of the White House
and their purview that decision I'm sure
is being discussed and the issues are
being discussed so I'm not gonna I'm not
going to defend what is what has or has
not happened there because that's
outside of our jurisdiction needless to
say and I think this is fair to say and
the American people are asking for this
transparency is important here and I
think one of the aspects of transparency
is what are in these documents and if it
doesn't put our national security at
risk I would think that it should be
something that should be released and
Declassified but you know what I said
you're not the president I'm not the
president either I don't get to make
those decisions about Bruce or and this
relationship would Nellie and
Christopher steel and the FBI was paying
Christopher steel well look they fired
they fired chrissteele because he's
leaking information he is lying ongoing
sonar and and but yet they're still have
Bruce or still having conversations with
them and they're you've seen the most
recent pieces that have been posted by
John Solomon and others I mean the fact
of the matter is that when you look at
this in its totality circumstances if
Sean it boggles the mind that this is
this is not
regular investigation this is irregular
I said the the corruption at the outset
of this has just been unprecedented I
think the American people are seeing
that for what it is all right